if you think the Internet has affected
your life aetherium will have that same
pervasive influence on our
communications on our entire information
infrastructure it's going to impact all
aspects of our existence
Joe Lubin is the founder of consensus a
Brooklyn based software production
studio that employs 68 people nine
countries the company which Lubin
started in 2014 is developing
applications built to run on an
ambitious new online computing platform
it's called a fearing theorem represents
a new paradigm in computing that puts a
lot more power and sovereignty in the
individual on aetherium the same types
of services offered by companies like
Facebook Google eBay and Amazon will be
provided instead by computers
distributed around the globe so how does
aetherium bring together these scattered
computers into one network by using the
groundbreaking organizational system
known as a blockchain which The
Economist has aptly dubbed the trust
machine it's the same technology that
makes possible peer-to-peer exchange of
bitcoins without a bank keeping track of
who owns what cerium is controlled by a
different kind of blockchain that's
specifically designed to keep these
scattered computing nodes in sync
forming one powerful network that could
one day match the capabilities of a
Facebook work Google
the internet over time became a set of
centralized services and systems
aetherium will enable the replication of
all those functionalities but in a fully
decentralized context but why do these
services that have already improved our
lives immeasurably need replication the
first advantage of aetherium Lupin says
is that it cuts out the middlemen that
thin command and control infrastructure
that does extract an enormous amount of
money
the uber corporation or the air B&B
corporation it will be possible to
realize that so that the central control
if there's any at all will extract much
less value from the whole ecosystem
the space-time continuum buckles and
bends around your every twist and turn
take the music industry though it's
already been thoroughly disrupted by the
Internet Lubin believes the computer
code running on aetherium can eliminate
the last remaining entities that stand
between musicians and their customers
online music stores like iTunes Spotify
and Pandora take a cut on every song
downloaded or streamed as you licensing
firms like audio socket Getty and Rumble
fish
so consensus is building you Joe a new
website for buying music online that's
run on aetherium it's merely software
that facilitates direct trade between
musicians and their customers in the
case of this song tiny human by British
singer-songwriter Imogen Heap
all revenues are divided between Heep
and her collaborators according to a set
formula and when users click to buy tiny
human the musicians receive their share
of the proceeds within seconds since
there's no intermediary it's going to
put a lot more value in the pockets of
the content creators another advantage
of running websites and aetherium is
that they can be designed in a way that
prevents anyone from censoring their
content in contrast to today's most
popular web platforms take the online
discussion board reddit in 2015 the
company shut down five forums for
offensive content and users cried
censorship so consensus is building a
new decentralized version of Reddit
called nonsense
a platform for unfettered speech that's
owned and controlled by no one but
reddit was dreamed up by two
entrepreneurs in 2005 before anyone
thought there would be a market demand
for such a service and the iTunes Store
was built by Steve Jobs who first had to
convince the recalcitrant record labels
that they had no choice but to get on
board with digital downloads in an
internet without intermediaries who's
going to stake money on the next
visionary idea the thing I still find
unsettling is weird - Steve Jobs and
Larry Page fit in well there be some I
don't understand why you think that
decentralization will kill creativity
and there are so many amazing people out
there coming up with great ways of
offering better solutions in so many
different niches if there is no single
insanely wealthy individual in all that
and I think there'll be lots of very
wealthy individuals and all of that but
that's great I think it is possible that
many many more really cool services
solutions will be built and maybe the
wealth will be spread out a little bit
more if Tyrion has another big advantage
over today's Internet
it makes government surveillance more
difficult as the Snowden leaks revealed
the National Security Agency has in the
past established direct access to
information is stored in the data
centers of nine major Internet companies
with aetherium there won't always be a
data center to gain access to and there
won't always be a company to serve with
a court order or force offline this will
also make run-of-the-mill government
regulation more difficult to enforce
but Lubin says that websites running on
etherium will be largely self-regulating
anyway take internet poker sites many of
which have been shut down by the
government for rigging games and
mishandling their customers money so
consensus is building an online poker
application on aetherium with no third
party company to cheat or steal users
maintain control of their own money and
anyone can verify that the game is fair
by inspecting the underlying code which
is open for anyone to see but just
because regulation isn't necessary
doesn't mean the government will
recognize that to be the case
Lubin says in many instances that won't
matter because with no intermediaries
there will be nobody to hold accountable
it won't be hard to stand up a business
that is located everywhere and nowhere
instead of having this choke point the
centralized corporation that you can
step on take information from or cause
to act in a certain way regulators will
have to go door to door and shut down
tens hundreds of thousands or
of different participants in the system
this is an unstoppable computational
machine
etherium x' underlying infrastructure is
being rolled out in stages but it's all
happening fast the idea was hatched just
three years ago in a white paper written
by then 19 year old prodigy named
Vitalik boo turin who is now the
project's chief scientist aetherium
officially launched last summer and over
the past eight months daily activity on
the network has shot up so who's paying
the bills at consensus Lubin says the
company is currently self-funded but it
has been rapidly striking consulting
deals with businesses that are looking
to incorporate aetherium into their
internal processes a libertarian should
care about a theorem because it gives
people the freedom to do the things that
they want to do control the things that
they are and that they own and
essentially transact in an uncensor Bowl
context